former heavyweight champ of the world
george foreman joining us on the program
George good morning how are you I'm
doing fine thank you ah first time you
met Mohamed Ali how old were you I must
have been about 20 and when it was the
most excitement the most exciting
moments of my life and where were you i
think i was around Madison Square god I
was gonna fight in Madison Square Garden
duh uh I saw him walking down the street
a crowd follow them around I didn't know
who he was I just saw a big crowd coming
down the street and then I moved and
waited as the crowd was coming closer to
the midtown Manhattan hotel and I looked
and it was Muhammad Ali did you say
anything you know this girl I was
quoting I tried to court her I taken out
to dinner maybe a year before and I was
really a handsome boy my effort was just
right and as I said to eat with her I
bought an expensive meal I couldn't
afford she said I told I was going to be
a boxer she's not seen Muhammad Ali he
was walking down the street saying how
beautiful he was he's look at me i'm
pretty and the only had on a t-shirt and
a pair of jeans she said and you know
what he was beautiful i'll put the girl
down had nothing to do with it again so
when that night walking out he just
crawled up deep in there and day was
once again just a shirt and bells legs
the man has a hit I'll feel so bad cause
he was beautifully but did you have any
idea that a few years later you're going
to be in the ring against Ollie no I no
idea you know I was on my way to a
championship for the world and they took
the title from him and he'd been in
exile so exile so I didn't think that I
thought that was the last of you but
then you're fighting your idol or one of
your idols i'm going to assume like how
how weird is wrong with it you that is
weird
you get into the ring and you start
hitting hitting hitting and then you
realize you you can't beat because this
cousins that he had this presence it was
something I've never seen before it
wasn't like a tough boxer a great job of
great right hand this presence was
something I'd never faced like that in
the ring before never before never again
after what a man but I just say he was
up to say with a great boxer is like
trying to put him down he was more than
a boxer I can tell you that but George I
remember that people were worried about
Ali after what you did to Joe Frazier
and you were such a big strong guy that
and then we watched the fight and ollies
on the ropes and and he's not hitting
back and you're just punching him with
everything you have I thought they were
going to stop the fight because Ollie
was not fighting what did you think at
that moment well you heard the stir
about the rope-a-dope yep well yours
truly the don't hear I'm the dope late
on a rope and I like a dopey I'm swing
until I just couldn't take it anymore
but did you think they were going to
stop the fight because Ollie one
punching you know I really put it on
this guy hit him with some hard shots by
the third or fourth round I hit him with
a big shot he looked at me as if to say
I'm not gonna take this then he decided
close his hands put his hands covered up
and said you know what I can't do it I'm
not gonna fight this guy and then after
when the bell rung he looked at me as
just to say I made it and I remember
looking at him and said he made it I
knew then i was in for a rough night
what's it do to your invincibility
because we look at you know like Mike
Tyson lost to Buster Douglas and then it
was he was different viewed differently
after that when you lost to ollie did
you lose something cyclods everything oh
you did everything you know just days
prior to that I traveled in from all of
them halfway around the world and people
would even look me now they were kind of
nervous and you know they combined
wouldn't meet our contact with me that's
how much respect and fear I had
that day after the fight the same people
were patting me on the back and saying
oh you get another chance from one day
prior to pity I was devastated you
became friends though with Muhammad I
you know I was I'm sitting in my home
and maybe 1977 1978 and my phone ring I
don't know how you got my number he
complimented me for about 20 minutes
said all kind of nice things about me
then finally said I should have known
something was up he's a George would you
do me a favor I said certainly he said
come back and fight Ken Norton for me
beat him up because I cannot beat in
George but he's afraid of you you can
beat him they're gonna take my title if
I don't fight him again he's and I just
can't beat it oh I said man up through a
more I'm leave Angeles now I'm preaching
I'm not coming back he saw trying to
tell me what about David he we fought
Goliath Bible all kind of things but we
stayed on the phone for days and months
and it ended up to be year that's how
long that that that telephone
conversation we became great friends how
good it promoted up the guy how good a
promoter lousy George he was the best
I've ever seen cuz you best i've ever
seen i learned to love him you see these
athletes now who you know have whatever
kind of comments that they'll make or
they'll try to show off or be a showman
and i always look at it go it's just a
watered-down version of what mom and
Ollie did you know all bad i can tell
you what and I'll tell everybody he was
the greatest show on earth I've never
seen anything like that you see him I
would and my heart would be fast and you
didn't want to leave him and then if he
sit and listen to something you had to
say it made you feel so good because
he's paying some attention to me and you
couldn't take your eyes off him uh I
hope to live my life long enough that
someone else will come on the scene and
excite me as much as Muhammad Ali did
did you want to rematch with Ollie
uh yeah like I said in a seven-round he
asked me six round I hit him real hard
he said that all you got joy I'm telling
you that was all I had forever with him
so you never would have I never want to
fight him again I acted like I did but
if you need someone like that and they
start screaming us all you got it's not
like I'm waking up in the nicest please
get a rematch don't wait him go hey it's
great to talk to you as always George we
appreciate the stories and hope you're
doing well thank you thank you alright
that's a George Foreman former
heavyweight champ of the world the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]